the agony isn't over for these families
their loved ones were killed in an
airstrike on a detention facility in
yemen-santa province
now they must sort through bodies to try
and identify their dead relatives
nearby rescue teams are hoping to find
survivors under the rubble
this is a crime to be added to their
crimes and this makes us more determined
to face their aggression we're calling
for all the relevant authorities to
investigate this
more than 80 people were killed in the
attack
dozens are injured or missing
i was sitting with my friends and then
the warplane came and dropped the first
strike on our ward a while later two
more airstrikes hit
migrants women and children are among
the dead
aid agencies say the houthis used the
facility to hold migrants who tried
reaching gulf nations to find jobs in a
statement read on air by saudi state tv
the coalition says the rebels failed to
market the detention center on a no
strike list
the alleged target was not included in
the non-targeting list according to the
mechanism approved with the office for
the coordination of humanitarian affairs
in yemen and was not reported by the
international committee of the red cross
the u.n is calling for a transparent
investigation but on the ground in yemen
houthi leaders say they're not to blame
for the escalating violence
we are looking at a very big crime and
there is a green light from the
americans to kill civilians that's what
we see by the targeting of the detention
center inside the province and the
continuous killing of civilians while
war criminals escape prosecution
fighting has intensified recently the
saudi-led coalition has launched
airstrikes on what it says are houthi
military targets
this after the group carried out an
unprecedented attack on the united arab
emirates last week more violence is
becoming a growing threat across the
region
it has the potential to spill over
whatever happens in yemen will not
remain
contained within yemen's borders it will
spill over to the neighboring countries
and i think that is specifically why
yemen is so important
[Music]
in a country already devastated by years
of war
the fighting appears to be far from over
katya lopez
al jazeera